no matter what you do in life  no matter what dreams you chase if you  have a degree to fall back on you're  always safe  well they don't tell you that there's  180 000 price tag attached to it  student loan debt has been steadily  increasing affecting approximately  44 million americans  it's just normal everyone does it the  student loan problem has reached  epidemic proportions i'm paying all  these bills and i have  nothing i know people that are planning  to die with that debt  you've agreed to pay it back when you  don't  give me your pound of flesh now  this is the most important financial  decision in your life  no one is going to stop you from  borrowing  it's not good debt every piece  in the system did what it was supposed  to do  certainly seems like a very large amount  of corruption  and the victims are 17 years old  the choices that they made now own them  and they do not know what to do is that  the american dream